in summary we continue to face a very
highly transmissible variant that is
causing a high level of community
infection however while it is far from
harmless its overall impact is less
severe than delta so using the framework
i described earlier we assess the
current threat level to be medium
however assuming the level of infection
and its associated impacts for example
hospital admissions falls or broadly
stabilizes we would expect this to be
reassessed as low in the period ahead
this has enabled cabinet to agree this
morning an indicative time scale for
lifting or converting to guidance the
small number of legally imposed
protective measures that remain in place
at this stage
so i can confirm firstly that the covert
certification scheme requiring certain
venues and events to check the vaccine
or test status of attendees will come to
an end next monday at the 28th of
february
the app which supports the scheme will
remain operational however so any
business that wishes to continue covert
certification on a voluntary basis to
reassure customers will be able to do so
second as of 21st march assuming no
significant adverse developments in the
course of the virus we expect that the
legal requirement to wear face coverings
in certain indoor settings and on public
transport will be converted to guidance
we will continue to strongly recommend
the wearing of face coverings in shops
and other indoor public places and on
public transport we also expect on 21st
march to lift the legal requirement for
businesses places of worship and service
providers to have regard to guidance
from covert and to take practical
measures set out in the guidance and the
legal requirement on businesses and
service providers to retain customer
contact details is also expected to end
on 21st march
citing officers governments obviously
must act lawfully and that means we
cannot impose legal restriction
restrictions when it is disproportionate
to do so as the situation improves and
the severity of the impact from covert
reduces we are therefore duty-bound to
remove legally imposed restrictions
but this should not be taken as a signal
that covid no longer presents any risk
to health because it clearly does so
even though certain measures for example
face coverings may not be legal
requirements in future we will still
recommend voluntary compliance as part
of the range of behaviors that will help
keep us safe as we manage covert in a
more sustainable and less restrictive
way
exciting officer let me turn now finally
to testing testing has been and it will
continue to be a vital part of our
management of covet however as the
nature of the threat and our approach to
managing it evolves so too will our
approach to testing
it is reasonable over time and barring
adverse developments to move away from
mass population-wide asymptomatic
testing towards a more targeted system
focused on specific priorities these
priorities will include surveillance
rapid detection of and response to new
variants effective outbreak management
particularly in high risk settings like
care homes and hospitals and ensuring
access to care and treatment for those
who need it
however it is vital that we make this
transition in a careful and a phased
manner
so in march by which time i hope we will
have more clarity from the uk government
on available resources we will publish a
detailed transition plan for test and
protect setting out our priorities in
more detail and describing the scale of
infrastructure that will remain in place
for the longer term
the plan will also confirm the duration
beyond the end of march of any
transition period during which the
system will operate broadly on the same
basis as now